I'm gonna make court talk to some guy  Khloe Kardashian calls out Courtney's  flirt game or lack thereof have you guys  seen her try to like talk to someone  she has no game at all and it's amazing  cuz I you just would think like she'd be  so poppin right totally Clos opened up  about her sister's dating life since her  split from Scott Disick in this deleted  scene from Keeping Up with the  Kardashians she's so like dope but  Kourtney is the biggest Jessie are you  talking about me now now khlo  you might doubt Kourtney skill but  clearly she's got enough game to hang  with her rumored new man  twenty-something model Yanis Benjamin  yep that's what he really looks like so  we'd say Kourtney is doing just fine  [Music]